greetings from podcastville it's monday
the 3rd of august a whole new [ __ ]
month
with a whole new set of [ __ ]
priorities
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by draftkings listen
draftkings is [ __ ] legit they're
based right here in the u.s
things may be a little totally upside
down but at draftkings
you can rest assured your money is
secure
deposit and take out money anytime at
your convenience
every day this week there are at least
six nba games
they're doing great in that bubble so
you're on a [ __ ] roll if you want to
make money this is the way to go
baseball is a little men's immortal
false positives the whole [ __ ] things
and draftkings has a deal for you place
a pre-game bet on any game
if the team you pick wins end up losing
but scores over 110 points you get your
money back
that's [ __ ] insane so listen
draftking sportsbook isn't available
where you live yet don't forget about
fantasy they're offering a shot at 1
million dollars
every day this week so get on the action
download draftking sportsbook now use
code church plus for limited time just
for the church family
all the new users get up to a thousand
dollar
sign up bonus only a draftking sports
book
deposit bonus requires 25 times play
must be 21 older new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania only
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details let me ask you
something you got a gaming problem
let's help call 1-800 gambler or if
you're in indiana
call 1-809 with it and tell him uncle
joey sent you
but if you're still gambling download
the draftking
sportsbook app and use code church
c-h-u-r-c-h
to get the [ __ ] party started
kick this [ __ ] muley
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
it's monday the 3rd august i know a lot
of you guys are hurting
that's why uncle joey's here never fear
with his [ __ ] trusted sidekick the
flying jew aka the christ killer
aka [ __ ] mush mr lee syed what's
happening you bad [ __ ] a monday
morning i know a lot of years are uh
it's a rough week benefits got cut off
you know
we talked about this back in march not
to depend on this that this was gonna
[ __ ] with you so they just took another
2 400
from me and there's nothing you could do
about it you know uh some people moving
with their families they saw a lot of
moving trucks
this weekend in california i mean a lot
in my neighborhood so
uh it's an onslaught but anyway we're
here and we're [ __ ] queer another
great week
on the church today we're going to talk
to you about a couple things
when's going to be a fast one today no
drama it's [ __ ] monday you got [ __ ]
to do
you got people to call and you got to
straighten out your [ __ ] life right
now because uh
this covet thing has taken over and it's
uh setting a mark
i think they're gonna close up a couple
states this week
we might get closed up so my heart goes
out to all the families
and my friends that are uh in need and
you know just going through a rough
patch and trust me
it's not you alone everybody's going
through this [ __ ] i talk to a thousand
people a day
and everybody's got a different [ __ ]
situation and the [ __ ] just keeps on
piling so please
do not do anything drastic do not put
this burden on yourself
do not beat yourself up this is just
another part of growing up
and that's all and that's that the main
topics today is that we are
leaving uh we're going to do the month
of april
uh the month of august the church of
what's happening now myself and lee
got some guests lined up and then uh
lee's going to milwaukee to work for a
month and he's like home for the winter
spend passover with mom whatever some
jew holidays eat some shitty crackers
get some lasagna take care of himself
and hopefully we reconnect again maybe
in january of february we might decide
you know
i wanted lee to uh go out in his life
it's time for leader i've had him held
up here for two days a week
for eight years and it's time for him
and i
to [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of dodge you
know well i mean
i i am i'm excited for the future it's
an exciting time
but i mean you say held up it's uh
i can't say thank you to you and
everyone listening it's
i feel like i've grown up
the past nine years here so it's i never
felt
held back or or anything but you know
what it's uh
i did all this stuff everyone says it's
scary it's not and it is
i i am scared but it's also very
exciting there's a lot of possibilities
it's scary and exciting at the same time
this is what i told everybody
in march i said listen now is the time
that you're gonna get to think
you're gonna think about who you are how
you became you
what it takes to be you and you're gonna
ask yourself
what is worth it what i mean it's been
five months for me what's today's date
the second
the third i think tomorrow is
today is five months since i've been on
stage
wow okay how do you know and i know a
lot of you guys hey i was a mechanic for
30 years i've been yeah i know
we're all feeling it 29 years and
today's five months
without getting on stage and i probably
will be canceling salt lake city because
uh i won't be in the area anymore so
we're we're set to leave
towards the end of august i'm going back
to new jersey uh
i'll move i got a house up in north
jersey um
you know my decision was based on one
thing i mean lee i got to be honest with
you and for the people listening
i felt really shitty the last four or
five days
i felt really shitty about one thing
that
you know the church our motto is and
everybody's motto is you know
uh it's a cliche you know what people
say that
the tough get going what's that well
yeah when they're going get something
well what am i doing i'm turning around
and leaving
and it feels douchey of me that's why i
explained to both you
steve simone and dean delray i wasn't
leaving here without you
you know you're leaving i'm not leaving
you here like there's no way you would
tell
talk me into stan because i know there's
going to be repercussions and i don't
have to call your mom
you and i both know your street's a mess
at night
my street's a mess at night i mean we
live in nice areas guys
i mean what do you mean nice we're
beverly hills no but we live in a nice
enough
area not to see what we've seen the last
two months
and uh yesterday i was really had a play
date with my daughter and
uh another little girl and their parents
and social distancing
you know mascon were the only people at
the park
and one guy came out of the trees you
got to see this guys
he just walked up to us and sat there so
by the way i'm thinking this guy wants a
picture
i don't say nothing my wife turns
someone goes can i help you and he goes
what time is it
my wife goes whatever whatever time it
is then he stood there like a [ __ ]
dozen bots like for three more minutes
and he goes can i use your phone and my
wife goes no
you gotta go and i told the guy you
gotta go
he goes i got a meeting at 11 15 at this
place
i don't know where it is and i want to
look it up i go we got no internet
connection what a [ __ ] park
you know where are you looking for you
guys i gotta meet at a space corps or
something like that
what the [ __ ] are you talking about he
came out of the trees then he's walking
back into the trees the kids are playing
and he goes and sits on the bench next
to the kids
i need this now i gotta walk to the car
and get the [ __ ] gun
i tell my wife keep keep your eye on him
i tell the other dad walk over there i'm
gonna walk to the car i didn't tell him
what i was getting
i went and got the [ __ ] gun i sat
down i didn't bother nobody
and i didn't even listen to me my wife
handled it
because i didn't i didn't the way i was
going to handle it wasn't going to be
good
to be honest i'd be a little bit more
scared of your wife i feel like
i was not even gonna get involved the
way i feel lately
unless it got physical and then i would
just shoot him there was no way of
looking back
i'm not putting up with this [ __ ] i'm
not putting up i'm too old
i'm too old you know i'm an old [ __ ]
man i'm not gonna put up with it i got a
little kid
and then we called my daughter and a
friend over we said every time he comes
by you move
and then he finally got it went back
into the bushes
but th this is what you're talking this
is what you you know
the camp by the park by the house you
know the benches
to a homeless now cops came today and
talked to them my wife said the cops
came talk to them and walked away cops
can't do nothing
they can't do nothing to you they'll
move when the cops are there and they'll
come back so now
we got homeless people at the [ __ ]
the nicest park in the world
so i don't want you guys to think that
i'm overreacting or whatever
i didn't think of myself this time if
this was just me and terry
i'd stay here i'd worry about i think so
but i don't
do you i mean i've spoken to ten
diehards
and now it's down to like four diehards
you know and i gave rick ramos the
advice three months ago
so that's what i did to myself last
night i had to give myself the same
advice listen
you've been here 23 years you did more
than you ever expected to do
you're gonna go home like a man you're
not gonna go home as a junkie
i'm not the same person i was when i
left i still got my friends intact
my friends are freeholder my other
friends
[ __ ] you know i'm living in an area
where i'm 20 minutes from everybody
and what am i going to go to studio 54
no
but i could still see my friends for 20
minutes i've been very lonely here the
last three years
it's a very lonely place it's a very
lonely place here you know guys
um you know how many times i stared at
facebook over the holidays and saw you
guys
getting together with family 10 people
[ __ ] night of the seven fishes and
all that [ __ ]
and we're over here eating the shittiest
[ __ ] pizza
you know we're over here eating [ __ ] and
listen i was invited to move to ro
with rogan joe is a [ __ ] sweetheart
uh he made me an offer i couldn't refuse
to be honest
if you know joe he may be an offer i
couldn't refuse
but i didn't listen i've been gone from
my area since 1993.
to be honest with you since 1983
i only went back for nine months in 93.
so i've been really gone from 85
except for a nine-month stint and three
days a year when i go back to do gotham
and the stress factory it really wears
i've only been gone for 10 years
and it wears on me like i haven't been
home for thanksgiving i just haven't
been home
i just you would ignore it yeah you
put the pain aside it swept under a
carpet
you know for years it was swept in the
carpet i've been thinking a lot lately
of my first 10 years here they were a
[ __ ] struggle
why would anybody do that you have to be
insane
i can't to be honest with you like when
people talk about living in their car
for comedy and you you talked about it
i don't think i i don't think i'd like
anything enough to live in my car to be
very honest with you
bro i loved calmly so much
i sacrificed everything it was
you know somebody hit me up on the
pantry on about cocaine addiction how
they
stopped doing it since they heard me and
stuff
the cocaine addiction and the comedy
addiction
were hand in hand thank god the comedy
addiction
won yeah i was addicted to comedy
okay the only way to get good at comedy
is to get addicted
to comedy what does that mean
hi we're having a party tonight are you
coming no
i forced myself to say no
for years not for 10 years
not for 15 years but for 20 years
so 2001 i knew
that the only way to get good at this
was to say
no you had to dive in headfirst i got so
committed to calmly listen if anybody
knows me
like timmy holloway listens a couple
kids i grew up with
even when i lived in new york in 93 i
walked all day
i was in great shape i rode a bike on
sundays i rented a bike and i wrote it
and
i always lifted weights i had a gym in a
gunman not guttenberg in north bergen
there was a gym on the bottom of
tunnelly avenue 93 i would walk there
from cliffside
lift weights walk up the hill and then
take a bus into the city and work
i've always been somewhat of a [ __ ]
shape guy
my love for comedy was so strong that i
forgot about my health
between the drugs and the eating i
forgot about my health
i didn't give a [ __ ] i pulled in boulder
in 95 i was pulling teeth out with a
wrench
you know i you know times i had
bronchitis
and i couldn't afford a doctor you know
there should be they should have been
10 judgments against me from different
hospitals i went to when i was sick
and i never even thought of paying them
i never saw those places again like i
never saw those bills again
it was just a no mad life i committed to
a no mad life
to be a really good comic in the
beginning you have to be a nomad
yeah eventually you get a girlfriend and
you get some support
and they work with you but you're a
[ __ ] nomad
so i've been a nomad until mercy was
born
when mercy was born i stopped being a
comedy nomad but now i had no choice
now i had to attack comedy from a
different perspective as a business
this had become a business now by 2013
my comedy fun days were over
i was involved in a business i was
involved in two businesses
i was involved in the podcast business
which i knew nothing about
and i was involved in the comedy
business which i knew a lot about
but i didn't know a lot about it and i
tell people all the time that
you gotta be careful for what you wish
for
be careful for what you wish for because
it might come true before you write that
thing down
in that [ __ ] notebook i want you to
think about what you're writing and what
comes with it
don't just tell me you want to be a
lawyer tell me why
and i want you to know what comes with
it
it's 50 hours a week of [ __ ] in the
office
30 hours a week of research you got to
protect the guy that took a kid's eye
out with a wrench and then [ __ ] them
in the ass and
you got to go home with a straight face
you know are you prepared to do all that
my friend just became a cop young kid
he's getting sent
you know he thought he was going to be
in a rye in the car and waving people
and pick up chicks no
they're sending them to a mental
hospital for the first year
where they throw [ __ ] at you and feces
and you have to walk and we have to wear
long sweatshirts and gloves and a hood
like a [ __ ] like a mexican wrestler
because people throw piss pissing you
and [ __ ] did he really want to be a cop
that much
so before you get involved in something
when tommy took over for me in 2013
on top of the podcast i was overwhelmed
man
i was overwhelmed and if it wasn't
for me learning from ralphie and joe
rogan
i took a little piece from both of them
and a little bit of richard jenny
and what i saw comics do and what worked
for comics if i didn't watch those two
guys as closely as i did
i wouldn't have been here today because
i knew
what ralphie had to do to live and every
week
when i pull out of that gym on thursdays
and i was just getting ready to get on a
plane thursday afternoon i would go this
is what ralphie should have been doing
on thursdays
and recovering that night and then doing
two shows and coming right back on
sunday
working on monday working out thursday
walking on tuesday and wednesday
whatever the [ __ ] you have to do
meetings
a podcast you know for a while there i
was running rampant you knew it
i would what about when we first started
yeah
we meet at 5 30 in the morning and eat
edibles and smoke dope and
and then we'd leave there at nine and i
i could go to sleep because i was
working nights you'd have to start your
day
i'd go start my [ __ ] day and then be
a dad and have the kids till 10
and then [ __ ] right and then deal
with the podcast companies and then the
[ __ ] agents
and it was a [ __ ] and i'm not crying
i'm not crying listen
i did more than i ever expected to do
i if i would have left here in 2006
after the longest yard
i would have been happy if you guys
forget i was quitting comedy
yeah right before i came you said you're
gonna quit what a year before you came
that's crazy i was just getting ready to
go
sell cars 200 yards from here
at a ford store i went over to the used
car department
they hired me i told them the truth
about my background they didn't give a
[ __ ]
because the sleazier they are the more
soft cars you sell
and i was getting ready to sell cars i
think the crazy thing about la
is you're just so busy all the time you
kind of forget what you did
so like that's that's what i've been
thinking about in the last couple weeks
is
yeah we actually did a lot and like you
you did this you worked on this
there's nothing to be sad about nothing
to be sad about
i'm gonna miss you [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna
miss you to death i'm gonna miss
your calls in the morning torturing you
i'm sure this is calling you at night
when you're on edibles
tricking you you know all that fun stuff
we found some stars today believe it or
not i was cleaning up today
and i found 125 milligram stars
how long have they been in there how
long have they been out of business for
three or four years and whenever
recreational started in california it's
when they ended it
and they're still good you want another
one [ __ ] it why not why not
i'm already gonna end up sleeping here
tonight
today i was here with my daughter my
daughter goes what's that on the floor
daddy
i go i don't know it's a vitamin it was
a [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] capsule oh no one of
those strong ones is [ __ ] oh
she didn't pick it up or nothing i just
saw it and swiped that [ __ ] up
as fast as i could we i mean yeah even
with this like we
like there's so many podcasts that have
started and ended since we started
ours that's amazing
i don't know any of them that are still
going there's like barely any
i know people who have started and ended
[ __ ] 16 podcasts and we've still done
the one
almost 900 episodes between like
live ones how many live ones did we do
20 or 30 of them
close 20s at least and i got 100 with
felicia
yeah which i'm starting to bring back
also what the [ __ ] you might as well get
the whole dictionary from a to z
learn how i went with felicia from
beauty and the beast
lee said come over do your own thing
you're crazy
you know i was gonna do one with just
lee remember the first time felicia came
over and saw it she's like i don't want
no pieces
we were crazy my back office that was
way before my daughter was gonna be born
way before that was the first office
that like we hung out like
the first when i first met you we didn't
even do anything for a while
we we made it to haha that crazy lady
with the headband just tried to suck my
dick she was a prostitute he just left
me there
and then like you would like i should
the it's a story i always tell
and it's the it's always gonna make me
smile one of the first things you had me
do is you
had me show you how to post a picture on
twitter not on your phone you had a flip
phone i think
on the computer and i did it and you
said you're an unadulterated genius
and that was it like you think we know
how to post a picture on twitter
and then we like we took bong hits i
turned red that one time because you
could put hash in the bong
we smoked the can no no no i looked like
a can
no no we had a can of coke and i emptied
it and i made holes in it the first time
you smoked ash
you smoked out of a can and you [ __ ]
and you started coughing [ __ ] oh i think
that's how you started getting wrong
guys
your face started getting red you had to
sit down for a minute
you took me to get fried chicken and i
was still [ __ ] up though i'm just
sitting there waiting to go get fried
chicken remember there was a place on
lancashire that was there for like six
months
it was like a soul food place yes yeah
you and your wife took me there
and i was just zoomed out that's it's
still a chicken place
it's a disgusting chicken place now
and last night they had a covered circle
they had a
they had last night at about eight
o'clock
i drove past there and i got to tell you
something
yeah there you go there you go i just
tasted it
it's still good they still got the
strength of 10 martians
i just i don't even chew it i just
swallowed that [ __ ] [ __ ] it
250 milligrams down that's it
my nephew came to town this weekend
nicholas and i met him here on uh
tuesday lee couldn't make it that day he
had one of his clients
he wanted to meet lee really bad he
called this morning i thought he was
he called yesterday morning i thought he
was leaving but when i called him back
last night i go you get
jersey okay he goes i'm still here i'm
leaving tonight i'm boarding in two
hours oh i thought did he get too [ __ ]
up or something
he [ __ ] i told him not to eat those
edibles
not like that he popped like two of
those capsules the first day
i gave him a thing of edibles of the the
capsules right
and i went to uh urban trees
and bought them the pills they were the
last of the pills
they're coming out with a stronger pill
this tuesday
oh god i'm buying a case of those to
take back the jersey with me
remember what remember tj english yeah
do you miss this flight because of the
market
oh my god poor dj english
it's just been like i said you know lee
and i
sat here and we discussed it one night
all the [ __ ] fun
there was a time this podcast took six
hours
oh yeah we six hours we did the pre-one
the pre-we would meet at six behind the
stairs
and you gotta see what that office looks
like oh yeah that looks like
[ __ ] you're gonna get shot up there
this was on top of the insurance office
we went through the back it wasn't
closed every time i left i thought
like i was walking down those stairs
they had like a little puerto rican
acting class
downstairs like just a bunch of shitty
actors i sat in the car one night and
watched him
the coach i looked him up he had been in
like a [ __ ]
he was like an extra and he was teaching
this [ __ ] it was
terrible he he called me over one day
goes we'd love for you to sign up here
i go let me get your information i
wanted his imdb he [ __ ] booked one
thing
the [ __ ] out of here with a bunch of
poor kids thank god
that all these people are leaving
because all these scams are going to get
re-evaluated now
all these big-time acting courses and
all this [ __ ] people are pulling here
this is the good thing about what's
going on going on here now
this is the revampment of hollywood
this is really the reventment of
hollywood
for anybody who doesn't know it's going
to be so
tough it's so tough to shoot right now i
spoke to my buddy from the voice
they don't they don't even go in and
every day they go in
just for the shoot and it is
like communist cuba
they have two the big time shows
the big time every day i get sag emails
and they tell me not to work on certain
things which i don't get a call to work
on them anyway
they just send you constant don't work
on this show
don't work on that show because i did
not know this
i thought that i thought that you had to
get two nurses
to put them on the set no you ready
it's like a 72-hour course like a
three-day course that you do online
and you get [ __ ] registered and you
become a culvert inspector
oh boy so actors are doing it now to
have work
so they i thought it was but those real
places like
the nbc shows the cbs shows they're
gonna have a nurse on duty thank god
they're gonna have a nurse and another
assistant like a
a certified person but then making you
stand
separate you know and if you see what's
going on with sports
the bubble does work you know what i'm
the first one that talked a lot of [ __ ]
about that fight island it worked
it worked and the nba
beside the escapees it's working
it's working okay baseball is not
working because they got to go home
every night
they got to travel and they got to
travel it's not going to work
do you do you know yet how they're going
to do school
where you're going in jersey where i'm
going i heard there's
five districts in jersey that are going
back to school
wow hoboken is going back five days a
week you got an option
i feel that's a little extreme right i
feel that's throwing too much spaghetti
against the wall for your child
especially in the winter so what i'm
gonna hop
for is the three day two day online
where i moved where i'm moving to i
picked
hand-picked because the school system
nice
you know the taxes there go to the
school
not like here that there's a 66 tax on
gas that we don't
even know about you know and
it's it's very shameful when you drive
to hollywood now
unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
drive down murrows you could tell
the economic recovery we're 18 months
away from economic recovery
if there is a vaccine by december
we are still another year away from
seeing people
bumping and driving yeah taxes are going
to go up in california
you know these people that sent you
these checks they aren't free
they're not free i don't want none of
you people to think that that 600
each you got a week that ain't gonna be
free
so get prepared for the [ __ ] finger
up your ass
and i've prepared you about everything
so far i told you not to depend on
unemployment
i told you just to get a job hustling
get your hustles together
lower your nut the car
get rid of it light it on fire who gives
a [ __ ] blame it on antifa
you know just light everything on fire
whatever you don't need guys listen when
you really evaluate your life
you look at things and you'd be
surprised what you go without
i was telling lee what weight watchers
is about weight watchers is about
what do you eat every day you eat 43
worth of points
we're going to teach you how to lower
that to 38
by doing certain things by not putting
ketchup on your fries
by only eating a half of fries by
realizing
that you don't need milk in your protein
shake you just need ice and a couple
[ __ ] ice cubes
and you start cutting points back you
know when i get blue cheese dressing now
i just get the dressing
no more chunky those chunks are [ __ ]
10 points
i would sit in a [ __ ] at a steak
house eating that chunky blue cheese
like it was going out of style there's
so many like every day you cut
back on something you know i haven't
eaten bacon
i've become a jew i stopped eating
[ __ ] bacon
which is you've always had babies it's
five points a day wow yeah
you know three stripes of bacon is five
points a day
you cut it down to two it's still three
and you're eating it seven times a week
that's 14 slices that's really going
towards your heart at 57.
do you need that bacon i used to eat
sunny-sided bags before the [ __ ]
thing
i switched it to scrambled eggs and
[ __ ] oatmeal
so every day i switch it it's either
scrambled eggs one piece of toast
a little bit of butter or six points for
oatmeal that's it
with cinnamon and that sativia what's
that chicken
stevia that's the t-rex it's called and
i'm good and that's what you're gonna
have to do with your life
you have to step back from your life
write down your bills
and write down what's gonna work and
what's not gonna work i'm gonna tell you
something right now guys
and i'm telling you this from experience
at this point
there's nothing on tv you can turn your
cable off
you're just getting depressed you don't
need to watch the news
you already know what you already know
that people are dying you already
you know you know all these things why
do you have to keep telling you
read go online read what you have to
read
and eliminate the other [ __ ] you don't
have to hear about
10 guys getting shot you don't need all
that negative [ __ ] in your head
get rid of cable get rid of it save
eighty dollars whatever the [ __ ] it is a
month
you can live on netflix and hulu e la or
pick one okay you know [ __ ]
you know get cut coupons yeah what about
because you've been packing too is it
isn't that crazy how much stuff we're
just throwing away
that we didn't need that i was keeping
in my house that i've moved to eight
different apartments
that i don't just don't need at all
listen i i donated
i didn't like i donated the books
that i had bought over the years the
gifts from bob lolingis and other
church members those would be those are
possessions to me
i packed those all up the rest of the
dumb [ __ ] i had how to grow weed and all
that
i put it on the school the school has a
little bench
and you can put your books there i put
the weirdest books there
i found money in those books i found
hits of acid
i found naked pictures of women in those
books whoever gave me those books with
[ __ ] praise
people give me books at shows about like
their authors
you know i had a time period there where
there was a company that was just
sending me books by office
for me to pick an author to get on the
podcast i can't read a book that [ __ ]
fast
they were sending me 18 books a week
jesus i gave all those away
[ __ ] i don't even know about navigation
and
i don't know nothing about that how to
make a bomb
i don't need that in my life you know
what i'm saying so i gave all those
books out
all the uh uh you know
pablo lingus has given me books that are
going to be in my shells forever from
pete rose to
you know cepeda to the picture from the
boston red sox i mean he just knows
what's to get me roberto clementi
bruce lee books all those books are in
the box
ready to go i've been doing something
every day you have to
tonight i'm tonight when i get home uh
yeah tonight i'll [ __ ] uh
load the notebooks and [ __ ] i'm gonna
give you a couple podcast notebooks
and we're gonna send some out as gifts
to bob lolingus and jb
machete and [ __ ] uh scott cunningham
and uh and my personal pit bull
uh deborah hubster i got books from
every year
all the guests from 2014
on yeah who the sponsors were what we
talked about
so i'm gonna i got those i found those i
looked through those and they started
crying
you know i opened it up and it was like
the pimp's name the guy from the [ __ ]
thing
i have i had he signed a book for me i
don't know what to give it away or not i
feel weird having that book
what's the book it's the art of the pimp
or something and he signed it
you know i think i got one of those i
think i saved mine maybe i should keep
it i felt weird but that
out of respect you might as well keep it
if you ever get aids
you can read it when you're in the
hospital whatever the [ __ ]
you know there was a couple guests i had
to get coke from to get on the show
oh yeah you know i won't even tell you
like i had to call a coke dealer
and the coke dealer would come over and
put it somewhere and i wouldn't even
touch it or look at it
i would trick the people and tell them
to come on i had to give them blow i
mean guys
you have no idea the behind the stories
and some of these [ __ ] stories out of
here
that we've seen that lee lee has seen
[ __ ] that we could sit here for hours
and [ __ ] talk about
lee has seen some creepy [ __ ] [ __ ] in
here that
it's just been a wild ride man it really
has and we have nothing to be ashamed of
like i said i'm a little upset i'm
leaving some good people behind you know
bret from subconscious jiu jitsu coach
anne from strength uh
whatever my other girl from strength
code
my other girl from you know it's
it's crazy keita from bully busters
my daughter is going to be so [ __ ]
upset
i could see he key to kisses and now
every day like i'm counting the days
like it's so
but mercy wants to go mercy really she's
excited
nice you know man
one day we were here doing a podcast her
and i
and she went into a diatribe
and it [ __ ] broke my insides
because it realized she was my little
girl she just didn't know what she was
saying
you know we got pimped out at kovacs
the this is the school district that we
went to
now this district over here has a lot of
great schools
you've got oakwood that's a private
school that's like 44 000 a year 50 000
a year for elementary school elementary
school you got campbell hall which is 44
000 a year
and there's another private school notre
dame academy
that's got to be you're kicking in 50
grand a year and these people nickel you
to debt
every time they see you their hand is
out at all those private schools
you can't believe you're paying 44. i
would not sign up for the 44
000 plan because i know 10 kids who went
to that school they're [ __ ]
i know one girl who went to that school
and she's not [ __ ] [ __ ] she's an
attorney
but besides that everybody else is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and plus how how can you just that's
what
a half a million dollars more for it
yeah
by the time we get through i don't want
to do that so for years
you know bert crysia everybody oh wait
till she goes to colfax wait till she
goes to colfax
let me tell you something first day i
walked in there when she was in the
first grade i'm like who went to school
here abe lincoln
the [ __ ] school is old and from the
first day they're hitting you for
[ __ ] money
they're hitting you up for money and you
look around and some of the parents are
celebrities they don't say nothing
but the first year was great mercy had a
great time
kindergarten [ __ ] tremendous teacher
we couldn't shut
the [ __ ] up about the teacher spanish
lady
sweetheart i still see her at different
supermarkets
you know we gave her a [ __ ] uh state
card
when she graduated kindergarten the t
the teacher was dynamite
first grade i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened over there
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened over
there my little girl was not that happy
she wasn't talking about school she's
still a happy little girl
but she didn't have that pep in a step
she had in the
in kindergarten teachers matter at that
age a lot the teacher
was not bueno guys something was not off
there and then like that october
we had to go to a school function
and guys this is way before the rogan
article and all that [ __ ]
nobody said nothing to me
and i sat there with my wife and then my
wife went there for a book sale
and she said that my wife's like where's
uh you know there was like spanish
history
and she goes where's the spanish history
and she goes we put them over there
because they don't buy anything
and she goes you don't realize that my
husband's spanish
you know and then my my wife
has an african-american couple that the
kid's good friends with
he heard it and he goes i wonder where
they put up
and where they put our [ __ ] and my wife
goes you guys are
by the spanish people like
african-american studies by the spanish
people
so my wife felt that she didn't say
nothing to me she never said nothing to
me she just felt it a little bit
no i'm not again you know me i don't
give a [ __ ] about systematic racism they
can suck my dick
i'm gonna run it till i run if you don't
like it sniff my [ __ ] nuts out
so we're here one day me and my daughter
we're doing a podcast on whatever the
[ __ ]
the ocean the solar system
and she goes into this diatribe when we
finish sometimes she sits down and she
writes
and make her write what she experienced
and how she thought she did you know
when we get here she has to outline the
paperwork
it's like an hour the video takes 18
minutes
no i got to watch one it was great to
see yeah i make a prep bit the whole
thing and
she goes daddy i don't like fancy people
and i go what are you talking about she
goes well
at the school she started naming names
of kids
and she goes they're just fancy and
they're not real
and they don't feel authentic and
everything feels off
and what she didn't know she was
describing gentiles to me
she didn't know it she just knew
something wasn't right
and she spit off a bunch of names and
i'm like oh my god
this little girl this little girl is
telling me what i think she's telling me
and she said she didn't like that that
she doesn't like the way those people
act
how they treated her she didn't like
that and they go what do you do and she
goes i just avoid them
you know she goes i just avoid them they
don't pick on her you know we had a
little problem at the camp and she said
the girl wouldn't leave her alone i go
mercy the next time she comes up to you
go into your [ __ ]
fight stance and she'll never bother you
again
and two days later the little girl said
something mercy went into a fight stance
and mercy's got a hell of a right punch
oh i got a kick too
and the kicks she's [ __ ] listen they
train her over there
like a little savage she needs to get
rattled
see what's gonna happen to her is what
happened to me
i had the tools but i needed to get
rattled first and then i realized how to
use those tools
and she's gonna be a deadly kid and i'm
not telling you this because she's my
daughter i'm just telling you because
when we came here today she had a mask
on
we were talking and i didn't have my
hearing aids on i'm like why do you got
the mask on
and she goes i've gotten so used to it
that i don't mind worrying
if it keeps me healthy and you healthy
she's a smart kid
you know i'm very fortunate my wife has
worked with her
i'm hands off there i [ __ ] up the
spanish and she avoids me like the
plague
but all these things were the reasons
why i'm leaving i would listen
i'm gonna i don't you know whether it's
a patreon facebook twitter
all the messages are always you know
thank you for helping us out you and
lead
i've lived through a thousand [ __ ]
things man
when i started this podcast with lee it
was for you to avoid the same landmines
i put myself
in mine [ __ ] landmines whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call
that we put ourselves into that's all
this podcast was about
it got humorous we had a great time but
you always got something out of it i
wanted you always to get something out
of this
that's the most important thing we
wanted you to get and to feel good
i read a like when we were three years
in i read a thing once that all we did
was complain
we stopped complaining you know we
focused on the meat
and the word i hate the most the
positive angle on the podcast
how to make you feel good do we need a
four-hour podcast it would just kill the
whole thing
you're gonna shut it off after an hour
and a half
so we gave it to you straight direct
we kept it short honest and to the
[ __ ] point
yeah every podcast has been different
some you don't laugh at
but you learn something some of you
laugh at some [ __ ] we say is just plain
out [ __ ] horrific
but you know what the whole time we've
had fun and guess what
i've become the man i am not because of
comedy
or prison or any of that [ __ ] you know i
became the man i am
because of you guys because for me to
sit here and talk to you guys
i had to walk the [ __ ] line i
couldn't just talk to talk
i had to walk the walk to show you guys
that you don't talk to talk talking is
for [ __ ] jerk offs
you walk the walk i told you i would be
here every monday and wednesday i'm
hearing monday and wednesday unless
there's a [ __ ] problem
even when i shot the movie in new york
did i not send you messages and [ __ ] lee
and [ __ ]
sponsors over the phone on tape my whole
thing was to get to you
i know where the [ __ ] you at i know you
i know you from your comments
i know you from your emails i know you
from the way you act
i know you i know bobble wingers i know
who
scott cunningham is i know these guys
you know i know sergio ortega sergio
ortega has been with me
since beauty and the beast when he wrote
us an email about [ __ ] his wife in an
ambulance and i'm like your [ __ ] nuts
or a hearse or something like that
ambulance you know uh it's it's been an
amazing
[ __ ] ride but the most important
thing i've gotten out of this is
that i've had to walk the [ __ ] walk
you guys would have not taken the ride
with me if i didn't why i ate edibles
side [ __ ]
you know in the beginning we would do 18
bongos speaking of which
it's bong hit time what the [ __ ] or
whatever you got a pipe a joint
take a breather why are we working so
hard here you know what i'm saying
speaking of i mean you said like we've
been consistent that was the
main thing from the beginning is you
would always talk about consistency but
for the first seven years we didn't take
a break we didn't take a week off we
didn't take
a day off in life there's no breaks
in life there's no breaks
somewhere in your mind in the american
society
you've decided that you need a vacation
vacations are earned as an american you
gotta earn a vacation
you people who [ __ ] uh get a credit
card and go on vacation on a credit card
shoot yourself you're never gonna work
that long if you think every year by
going on vacation no you put away money
to go on a vacation but before we even
go on vacations
did you [ __ ] earn it who the [ __ ] are
you that you need a vacation
you don't do dick you don't do dick you
know what i'm saying
you got to earn vacations i wanted to
teach you guys that
holiday you know there's something i
hate about i love the holidays i love
christmas i love thanksgiving
i don't like the brain death just
because it's christmas now your brain
dead december 8th
you're thinking about oh well i want a
nintendo i don't give a [ __ ] what you
want it's the eighth
snap out of it come on it's the eighth
we're [ __ ] 20 days away
we'll burn christmas on the 24th but
right now i need you here
this is why i've never liked holidays
you know
a week before the 4th of july in l.a
there's not an audition
there's not i'm lying to you i booked my
first commercial fourth of july weekend
uh taco bell but this is why i didn't
believe this in life
for years when i was growing up i saw
these people who went on vacation
i was friends with them and then they
come back and tell me how much they put
on a credit card
i never understood it that's not what a
credit card is for a credit card is for
emergency now you guys
are paying off those [ __ ] credit
cards from stupid [ __ ] you did
don't you wish you had that money to
burn now exactly
because now all you got to do is make a
minimum payment they'll keep giving you
credit on the 34
and call them up and ask them for a bump
they're giving out bumps like [ __ ]
blow jobs now
they're giving out bumps right now on
credit cards do not believe
no call your credit card and say i need
an extra nickel over there
he'll they'll give it to you if you pay
your bills every month on time
and then you're paying the minimum
payment they'll raise your level
you will not go without groceries well
yeah well they want you to pay the
minimum payment yeah
pay the minimum payment so they can get
you who gives a [ __ ] you pay the minimum
payment
and you're out of the [ __ ] weeks no
but your interest keeps going up what
are you gonna do
hey there's no debtors prison i'd rather
you not starve to death
right absolutely i don't want nobody on
this show starving to death i'd rather
you [ __ ]
do whatever you can cut a deal with the
landlord tell them you ain't getting
dick
you know what i'm saying cut the tv and
just put a sofa against the door
they're not getting in there you know
i'm saying [ __ ] it they're not getting
in
you have to worry about yourself right
now you have to make the right decisions
for yourself right now
there's nothing wrong with going home
and living with mom
you think let me ask you [ __ ] a
question you think if my mom was live
and had a basement
i wouldn't get an airbnb for two weeks
and the quarantine and then moving my
mom
[ __ ] like judas priest said you got
another thing coming
but i think i told lee go home and be
with his mom because everybody right now
needs to go back and start all over
again if i had a mom
i'd be close to my mom if i had a dad
i'd be close to my dad
i'd go ask questions
i'd go ask questions about what my
family was about
what is all this stuff about um
i try to find out who the [ __ ] i was to
the t
sometimes going home centers you
believe it or not i know your mom's a
pain he asked and your dad asks a lot of
questions but guess what
i don't have a mom and a dad i would
give my [ __ ] right hand
to go home and seek knowledge from my
mom or my father right now if i had him
or a brother or an older sister or an
older brother
so right now don't be ashamed about
going home if you have to pack your bags
and go back to
oklahoma or missouri or [ __ ]
wisconsin
or [ __ ] jersey there's no shame in it
you know and
my shame wasn't leaving here with a slap
to my face
my shame is that i'm leaving a lot of
friends
uh behind i feel like i'm leaving
vietnam
this is vietnam this has become vietnam
for some people what is vietnam
[ __ ] you never thought you would ever
see in your life
[ __ ] that nobody expected to see in
their life
but you also have to i mean you have to
take care of yourself you can't
you're not in charge of other people's
lives and you can't you can't hurt
yourself
because of other people that's great
it's not my dna
i worry about my friends why i have
friends
if you don't sincerely [ __ ] worry
about them and their health and their
welfare
why do you have friends that's another
reason why i'm leaving here
there's no friends we have hollywood
friends here
i'm not saying nothing bad i have a lot
of good friends here
but they're not the friends i grew up
with they're friends
but they're not the friends i grew up
with comedy just doesn't provide that
for some reason comedy makes you be
friends but uh
not really you know speaking of which
uh there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
in the news and uh whatever and i'm
gonna throw my two cents in
because uh you guys have always listened
to me
and uh you know i'm a no-nonsense type
of guy especially when i talk about this
type of [ __ ]
i'm a criminal i have no reason to lie
to you about that
i've done a lot of criminality [ __ ]
there's one word in my vocabulary i was
hurt
i was i was raised to hate
this word and
the word is rape i don't like that word
i've never really liked that word when i
was 10 i made the mistake
and uh behind my mother's back i went to
see the movie death wish
the first one it's a horrific fur it's a
horrific scene for
a child to see if you haven't seen
deathwish
watch it i remember sitting in that
movie theater and watching this woman
get raped brutally
and saying to myself that could be my
mom
and that feeling went away and then
years later i found out about
that my aunt rosita was getting raped at
a [ __ ] party in cuba
and my mother broke a bottle heard her
getting raped in the bushes
and she stuck the bottle on the guy's
back and ripped them open
and my uncle told me she came home with
a white dress on covered in blood they
had a rusher out of the country
so growing up my mom had a a certain
thing you know like when she raised me
you know it was just something there was
just something
about that word that has always bothered
me when i when i got locked up
i talked to anybody i don't care if you
sniff glue
i don't care if you kidnap somebody i
don't care if you lit a house on fire
i don't care if you i didn't care about
the drugs i didn't care what drug i
don't care if you sold
i didn't talk to rapists of pedophiles
they were kept aside
everybody knew who they were you didn't
talk to them
every every three months one of them got
a beat
and the cops didn't the guards didn't
care
you know what are you gonna do how can
you yeah every once in a while the guy
used to hang out with in jail
clark there was one pedophile that he
would beat the [ __ ] out of once a month
knock his tooth out one night he knocked
his [ __ ] tooth down guy went to the
[ __ ] kitchen the next day with a
missing tooth eaten breakfast
there was nobody he could run to because
everyone makes mistakes but those things
are like
that's not a mistake you can't make i
mean i don't i don't
just something about that whole word and
i'm no [ __ ] angel but i've never
raped anybody
okay uh friday or thursday i wake up to
allegations
against uh what's his name brian callum
now i've known callan since 1999
maybe 98. i met him through my dear
friend and brother joe rogan
uh brian callan has always been
a ladies man had the pleasure
of going with him in 2001 i didn't go
with him
he was there when i got there to uh
acting cold reading workshop
and that legitimized our friendship we
sat together
we shared notes and after that he lived
in new york
for years brian cowan and then he came
to l.a and that's when i would see him
and we became tight through joe
and we went on different things together
different road events together but
uh you know there'd always be abroad
you know what i'm saying they'll always
be abroad it's talking to
a girl that would come to the show
nothing no
young girls no nothing they were just
normal girls
and sometimes he would leave with them
and sometimes he would talk to them
until we all left and we'd leave
together
how well do i know brian callan
i know him well guys i know him well
do i see the word rape in brian callan
no do you see the word rape in ralphie
may
when ralphie may got accused of rape my
[ __ ] insides flipped
my insides are still flipped about that
you know what
whatever you want to say you're going to
say before you accuse somebody of rape
or make accusations of rape you know
what especially
21 years later and i know women get
silenced i know that
you know what man if you get raped call
the [ __ ] cops
make it easier for everybody now 21
years later
you're upset in the natural balance of
things and i'm not a houdini
i don't know if you did i don't know
who's lying here
i just know who brian cowan is and
you guys know i'm not a i don't know
about psychotherapy i don't know about
nothing about anything but i know human
beings i study human beings i [ __ ]
study him
and does he sling dick yes
is he a rapist no no
no no so i just wanted to give my piece
on that he's a dear friend
i called him immediately as a matter of
fact last week
i met with crystalia just to look them
on the face
talk them off the ledge and let them
know i loved the kid
i seen the emails i saw the listen for
me
i'm from a different world okay you
ready for the world i'm from
are you ready to press charges you got
charges to press
no then shut the [ __ ] up
if you can't press charges shut the [ __ ]
up
shut the [ __ ] up if you're not prepared
to come to me with the evidence to
prepare
charges shut the [ __ ] up
i am not i told you this
last year guys when that [ __ ] judge
got accused of covering the girl's mouth
that this was gonna be trouble
i knew it would be trouble for me it
would be not in a sexual way
but right now anybody can say anything
we're living in a world
where anybody could say anything
all i want you is to do is to
let's be honest let's do like law and
order
present the evidence from both people
and let me make an educated [ __ ]
guess here
present the evidence from two people and
let me
and then let me make the obvious [ __ ]
decision is that fair america
is that fair england is that fair the uk
is that fair panama is that fair china
is that [ __ ] fair enough colombia if
you have
the proof i want lee's story
and i want the broad the ladies story
right in front of me and let me make a
decision if we have enough to press
charges then i'm wrong i owe you an
apology and i'll drop the [ __ ] out of
the world
but if you're not prepared to press
charges do me a favor go [ __ ] yourself
have you been accused of something you
didn't do
doesn't [ __ ] feel good doesn't feel
good let me tell you something
in the heat of my [ __ ] thievery and
[ __ ] there was a point where i was
getting accused of everything
and i accepted it because i had to i was
a thief
they weren't lying but i didn't do that
particular job
there was a lot of things there was
something that really really
edged me on in 85 a dear family i was
friends with
when i was living in cresco accused me
of robbing the house
you want me to tell you something i knew
the accusations were coming
hey it was 1985 it's 2000.
i've told you things i don't tell
anybody else guess what
i didn't rob that house i was accused of
it
it really did something to me you know
i got accused of robbing a lot of [ __ ] i
didn't give a [ __ ] i had no interest in
those people i don't give a [ __ ] they
were just drug dealers
but there were people that i really
cared about i got accused of this
it ate me alive for years it hit me
alive and just last year i went home
and the kid who robbed the house i guess
went to aaa
and you got to tell your sins you know
you got to tell everybody you [ __ ]
over
and he went to the family and cleared
his name or something like that really
yeah oh [ __ ] so and i wrote a blog about
it years ago and the guy hit me up on
fate
on myspace when i was writing blogs on
myspace i wrote a story about how much
that really
hurt my feelings i remember getting
accused and
the first thing i did was i called the
chief of police
gerard bazako senior he's still alive i
think hopefully
if not god bless his soul i called him
direct
and i said listen i've been accused of a
robbery in north bergen
what do you want me to do you want me to
go down and give my fingerprints because
i didn't do it he goes let's hold off
and see what the evidence is he goes
detectives went up there
i never heard anything back again but i
was willing to fight for my life
i did i know what i robbed and i know
who i robbed
and i had not robbed these people also
was it because
you had a relationship with him like as
as a thief why were you like why
why did it bother you so much
because they were false they were false
accusations
and it pissed me the [ __ ] off it hurt me
to the end
i deserved it i had it coming i'm not
gonna say the entire didn't have it
coming
if i tell you that then i'm wrong
but just how i felt
was horrible you know this whole thing
that went on six weeks ago
i went from telling the story that was
a story on the fly that i had forgotten
about
and i even said it in a weird [ __ ]
way i never even performed in the belly
room in those days and i said belly room
you know even after that happened i read
things i could read
i read what they took with the little
thing
and how they blew it up into coercion
they used the word rape they used a
bunch of words and i was like oh we're
living in a bad
we're living in a bad space right now
we're in a bad space mentally
if you're looking at all this you know
two weeks ago they canceled brian
cowlins and delia show
and i read the article in the la times
but i saw it on twitter
and it went from crystalia to crystal
lee allegations
to harvey weinstein nobody deserves that
delia sent the [ __ ] email to an
underage girl without knowing
harry weinstein raped and [ __ ] cut
deals with women to put him in movies
big [ __ ] difference in my world big
[ __ ] difference in my world
okay am i mad at harvey for the rape
[ __ ] yeah he's a big piece of [ __ ]
am i mad at harvey because the chick
sucked this dick to get a role in the
movie
look what they did to marilyn monroe
they killed her to death with dick
they [ __ ] marilyn monroe to death and
they they hit it with a hover
they shot her with something they killed
like michael jackson
you think about this [ __ ] you know look
at how marilyn monroe died i don't
[ __ ] know
some pills i don't who the [ __ ] knows
you know they killed her to death they
[ __ ] to the debt
between the kennedys sam g and connor
this guy that guy everybody was giving
her dick you know
everybody's surprised by what goes on in
hollywood do not be surprised
there's some victims but some people go
in there
knowing what time it is from day one i'm
sorry to put this bluntly
and if you get offended well then get
offended but i'm telling you
that this comedy scene this movie
entertainment scene
this is the creepiest world you'll ever
enter in your life
okay you saw a couple weeks ago will
smith and his wife
you know you're seeing this this is
opening up right in front of you let you
people know
we live and [ __ ] all these people that
you watch on tv
that you're in love with guess what
they're not the people that you think
you are
and here you are watching them thinking
what do you know what does ellen
degeneres do now
did she need this [ __ ] i've heard that
from the ellen show for years for years
i've heard that
[ __ ] very depressing for years but you
[ __ ] think she's a [ __ ]
savior
oprah on the other hand runs a good [ __ ]
okay there's a big difference
and i want to say about the people that
you've brought onto the show
there's some people who haven't been
nice to me there's some a couple weirdos
but for the most part everyone that i
met like for me to be able to meet
ralphie was
very cool for me i i i knew about
ralphie growing up
and he he treated me with nothing but
love gabriel came in here
[ __ ] who just so many other people
came in here that
that there are still good people in this
town
but you have to search for it there's
very good people in this town
i saw george perez today you got steve
simone you got dean del rey i mean i'm
worried about dean del rey
reason to stick it out move to the
desert or move to arizona
you know uh i heard steve burns moving i
spoke to theo this weekend he's in
nashville looking at houses
he went fishing you know i mean uh
nobody's giving up
nobody's badmouthing nothing nobody's
saying nothing what i'm trying to say
is you have to know in your heart
when something's over when i see
what mercy and myself and my friends are
facing
i feel horrible for lee even though he
knows i love him to death
for the last month we could have been
out of here the last year we could have
been out of here
he could have been he could have gone
back to law school
lee stays around for me for two days a
week for five days he sits there waiting
for [ __ ] the blue bird happens to
show up
i know what you go through buddy that's
why i call you i torture you
i i give you edibles i try to brighten
your life the only way i know how to do
it
dude you might you're my your my your
family out here the only family i like
i moved out here knowing nobody and it's
very weird but
like this is a place where if you live
10 miles from somebody
you're not going to see you're not going
to say it and you you i remember going
to
i didn't have anywhere to go for
thanksgiving and i remember having
thanksgiving at your house when
there were people there and then for
most people might have been a sad
thanksgiving but looking back it was
funny
i remember your wife was so pregnant
that she didn't even eat
and we sat down just me and you yeah we
sat on the couch and watched tv
and it was depressing but it was good
but it was still fun
it was great and that's what i'm saying
listen by living out here you give up a
lot
in this world you give up a lot it's not
the sacrifices of getting the nose at
the audition
and netflix doesn't want you that's not
enough
you're without the people who took care
of you all your lives
and after 30 years i got really sick of
not having that
when i went home last year for the
sopranos
it all came back to me so
we're gonna keep doing these i think
we're gonna try to go
uh for you to have episodes till uh
september we're gonna release some
surprises for you
never before seen surprises for you
and uh who knows what's gonna happen
uh i want the best for lee i want the
best for you guys
and i know you want the best from me as
of right now
twitter stays instagram stays
i don't know what i'm going to shut down
on facebook my heart goes out to scott
and you know he tried really hard to
create something pure
and uh you know scott cunningham
will always be to fearless leader i'm
going to talk to
my management this week about putting
some type of board together
for the church and it's scott cunningham
run
uh hubs the [ __ ] this is personal
bulldog
hobson decides everything she bit slaps
everybody
la lingas is the treasurer we'll figure
it out with bob lalingus
you know we're going to make a little
committee i know which one of yous are
really in
which one of yous really want to have a
good time and which one of yous really
want to stay family
with me because we created a family and
i don't want you guys to
leave anywhere that's why i created the
patreon for a dollar i don't give a [ __ ]
what's a dollar dollar gonna change it
i you know i have a lot of fun on the
patreon the other night i got [ __ ]
stoned did bedtime stories
on patreon you know why and i i was
gonna go in my daughter's room and get a
book
and actually read you a bedtime story
which i'm gonna do this week one night
for you
i'm just gonna pick a book like i told
the lead i told the three little pigs on
the run i don't know the three little
pigs
he huffed and puffed he had copd
whatever the [ __ ]
but this week i'm going to read you a
bedtime story on patreon a real one
every every every week from now on one
night
it's gonna be like a three minute video
of me just reading your bedtime story
all right
and with that said i love you guys with
all my heart i have uh
this has been a real [ __ ] pleasure
for me what's happened with this
just all started by telling the story
about lightning hooker's wig
on fire and you guys never backed out
after that if i would have heard that
story i would have shut that channel off
and ran the other way not you
[ __ ] you guys said on
some of you is left you came back you
know it doesn't matter
you'll always be part of the church and
with that
the church is brought to you by
draftkings listen draftking sportsbook
isn't available where you live yet
don't forget about fantasy they're
offering a shot at one million dollars
every day this week
draftkings is legit they're based right
here
in the united states a [ __ ]
america not in some [ __ ] bahamian
bank
things may be totally upside down out
there with what's going on
but at the draftkings you can rest
assured your money is always
[ __ ] secured
deposit and take money out anytime at
your convenience
now i don't know if you [ __ ]
know this but every day this week
there's at least
six games six nba games you understand
me
not to mention corona ball baseball i
don't know what's gonna happen there
but this is the time to bet baseball too
if you get a line why not
draftkings has a deal for you place a
pregame bet on
any game nba if the team you pick
to win end up losing but scores over 110
points
you get your money back that's [ __ ]
insane i've never heard anything no one
does that
nobody does that so right now go to
draftkings right now okay
get in on the action download the
draftking sports book now
and use code church c-h-u-r-c-h plus for
limited time
just for the church family all new users
get a sign up bonus of a thousand
dollars
did you hear me in the back you get a
grand when you get draftking sportsbook
app
and use code church right now we got
basketball every [ __ ] day this week
let's go [ __ ] next week you got
[ __ ] the ufc you got
steep a against dc that's coming up
so right now if i was you football's
around the corner now is the time to
make a little bit of baccala
just a little bit don't be greedy just a
little bit pick yourself a team every
day you watch them
you know this is the way to do it
draftking sportsbook isn't available
where you live yet don't forget about
fantasy okay
because this week i told you they're
gonna offer a million dollars
every day this week so dr download the
draftking sports book now
did not and here's the part the lawyers
make me want you to say all right
you got to be 21 and older new jersey
indiana
and pennsylvania only deposit bonus
requires a 25-time playthrough
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
what book for details listen you're
sitting there brought to pieces
every day this week there's basketball
cut this [ __ ] they're giving you a deal
that you can't [ __ ] lose with
draft cream sports book isn't available
where you live but right now
who gives a frenchman's [ __ ]
restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details and
do me a favor if you got a gaming
problem there's help
call 1-800 gambler g-a-m-b-l-e-r
or if you're in indiana call 1-809 with
it
and tell them uncle joey sent you but if
you're still [ __ ] gambling
right now download the draftking
sportsbook app
and use code church i want to thank cbd
lyon
i want to thank uh draftkings draftkings
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys for being here for eight years
and i want to thank you guys for
continuing to be here okay
uh i'm not going away lee's not going
away we're still going to be in your
life
at least once a month we'll figure
something out but for right now
i have a great day today if you're
having a bad day i'm sorry
uh this is going to get worse but you
know what we're going to get through
this together i love you [ __ ]
have a great monday see you back here
wednesday morning
tip top magoo ready to go kick this
[ __ ] mule league
[Music]
you